let's get directly into audience
questions for the week you can send
these in really however you want but the
best way is to use the contact form at
david pakman.com put audience question
in the subject maybe your question will
be answered next week first question
today how if at all will the virus
pandemic affect the 2020 election well
there's the there's two ways to answer
that it depends who can take credit or
avoid blame for what happens between now
and the election that is attributed to
kovat 19 so as an example if we continue
to see stock market's decline and
there's a global economic slowdown
that's attributable to kovat 19 then
it's quite feasible that it will
negatively affect donald trump's
reelection chances and as i've said
before a lot of this stuff is perception
the perception of the economy is a top
voting influence when when when you
think about what is going to motivate
people to get out and vote or not to
vote to go out and try to re-elect the
president versus try to remove a
president and often the perception is
not actually in line with the reality
but that's effectively irrelevant so if
Donald Trump if scenario one kovat 19 is
effectively controlled over the next few
months and Donald Trump can take credit
for it he's already taking credit for it
even though things are getting worse and
worse that is likely to help Donald
Trump's reelection in that the sort of
average voters may at least see Donald
Trump as not having made the problem
worse and presided maybe over it being
resolved if you believe that's the path
forward if kovat 19 continues to spread
and the stock market continues to not do
well and there start to be broader
economic concerns that perception
regardless of its reality is likely to
hurt Donald Trump remember that back in
2008 when the economy started to implode
in advance of the November 2008 election
that did at that late stage in the
election campaign of Barack Obama
did help him it did help Democrats late
in that race there's also the idea that
not only would covet 19 continuing to
spread and claim more lives every single
one of them tragic and and and horrible
it's possible that this will not only
hurt Donald Trump because you will be
seeing as dealing with it poorly but
it's also conceivable that it will
remind people of how our health care
system is fundamentally not working
remember that we heard from Donald
Trump's head of Health and Human
Services last week saying if and when we
have a cure and or vaccine for kovat 19
it may not be affordable to everybody
and that is very much front and center
in putting people sort of in the mindset
that maybe a different health care
system would be better suited to deal
with something like this if you are a
wealthy person who has no problem
affording care you are still at risk if
poorer people can't afford care
screening treatment are avoiding going
in to get checked which might lead to
being diagnosed which might lead to self
quarantine walking around going to work
because they can't afford not to so
there is also a way in which kovat 19
could very much backfire on Donald Trump
it could become Donald Trump's Katrina
so to speak and then there's the very
sort of macabre pact practical reality
which is every candidate that's running
right now including Donald Trump is
either over 60 or over 70 Amy Klobuchar
is almost 60 years old
they're out there all the time shaking
hands with people if this continues to
spread there is also the mathematical
reality that any or many of the
candidates could themselves be be
affected personally by catching kovat 19
and that's another question mark
altogether so there's no doubt
particularly as we see the numbers not
improve and worsen in many ways that
kovat 19 could play a role in November
of 2020 who it helps who it hurts is
certainly of political significance and
my priority is no matter what Don Jr
says people on the Left don't want
anybody to die because of Kogut 19 it
was so irresponsible for him to
that it was so irresponsible for Mike
Pence not to immediately say I don't
believe any of our elected officials are
looking for people to die Michael Pence
did not do that and that's a horrible
reality as well